ladies and gentlemen very glad to be
here to the ppt talk about our a program
in general University so it's not the
first one think we have move our
universities pretty typical in code
Harry work based on the archaeology and
gradually extended to the conservation
and cultural heritage protection so here
is the location of our University engine
eye area and our jobs subject of ecology
appeared a free early back to the the
beginning of last entry and we create
our speciality in 1972 and get to
dictate this printer this line of local
problems in 2006 and they start
demonstration Center in 2009 and it in
the past two years in 2012 got to top
three subject in China so this year we
will have another repetition it's a
joint international laboratory it's
mainly based on the cob regime with your
doctor and the hill is here we see you
and Stefan Museum in Chicago so we
character over 20 years completion in
Costa gender Coast area of China so this
that was a foundation of a subject so
any a university we have run to 27
faculty members in our department we
have also
the Institute afore called heritage in
museum so from the the end of last entry
or nineteen nineteen ninety-five we have
we character the coverage in which the
with foreigners to that we you know
promote our developing in the reason in
20 years here is the books here is the
laboratory we now so far into Tory's
eight laboratory focus on zoo
archaeology are kaput a knee and the
physical anthropology even ask top a
analysis laboratory and the years we
extended to the conservation to the
archaeological materials organic and
meadows also the new ones laboratory k
vision we cut the you know the burials
into the into the library to get river
will did very carefully k vision a lot
of new discoveries in our laboratories
and also we developed to the ecology of
such site protected you the add alliance
so we all see that in in the other
slides so here are we this is a
education and a research field we have a
very systematic training program from
the be a MA and a PhD I'll college
students were joined a fusible at least
once during in the Sabrina season like
today like the we had come back we have
too few schools open in Shandor and the
beyond and the research mainly focused
archaeology focus on prehistory historic
period and musial aaj and the culture
heritage musial RG and the code hatred
is pretty new in our University it's
also pretty typical in China mostly
ecology p star history and
to develop 2d science-based ecology
laboratory work and also musicology and
the culture heritage studies so I should
mention international coalition's it's
really bring us new ideas and the method
of archaeology so here is a
archaeological survey for curry surrey
in its gender legalization in young
children it's a four thousand five years
ago in a lunch and culture it's a well
know in prehistory in China a later
later period of a prehistory and the map
stood the corporation universities in
the institute is indeed win World it
differ in the country's here I made some
a friend from you say oh yeah we have
some crude you know collision with
yourself in a key but any studies yeah
yeah these years I like i mentioned to
we exchange our work to side protection
this is that the third one we we we are
doing now to protest site to protect a
Bronze Age site in chendo you know not
like in mid aged in China it's a problem
to come from developing of economic
because during the these thirty years
now Wendy you know industry come to
developed very fast economic fast but
many site particularly in the in the in
rural area the site was occupied by high
traffic highway and an array servers and
many things come from many problem come
from develop like this site it's a not
just cosas site it's a it's a close to
the two
villagers that because it's located yeah
very good traffic points so the crazies
come from these so we try to protect the
to plug the site totally probing and a
vision site and decide which period
which would be different function how to
use the Site how to protect site that's
what we we are doing now so downturns
inside is that the coverage incite we
with ill and it's a local museum
collections and these huge monies it's a
user looted barriers a huge amount so
usually we we work with these things we
refilled refilled the barriers better if
the small-scale better like these we
will do a really key vision is okay dr.
ND hills we'd also do public public
authority to local citizen so it's a
hero with what do we have that thank you
very much
you